please I mean we had so much fun I loved
watching you knock the crap out of that
guy at the airport so but I didn't I
know you didn't write song sorry Selina
Wow I was with my family like that was
the most heartbreaking part I was with
my kids and everything for him to
approach me and strike me in my face
like that was unbelievable but like I
don't get no points I'll be doing that
like Mendez
that's what I'm saying like not bragging
and then I used to I used to fight every
day but like I don't I don't want to be
known as keep fighting like all right
I'm saying like yeah I know but like
yeah cool but like why should I have to
go through that [ __ ] in the airport when
I'm just walking with you in my family
like that [ __ ] is ludicrous you know I
mean did you know this guy like did this
come out of nowhere never met this guy
after my lawyers I'm done did their
homework with this lawsuit that we might
be shown he had just been in Atlanta for
I think three weeks when he was working
for the airport right now I never met
this goddamn alive that's not what I'm
about right now you get I'm saying like
I got a 12 yard or who can read and
who's all AIDS on a row students
I almost take it damn near college
classes in a second Barry I got another
stem yo that's reading on us what sixth
grade level so they read everything
right now like and in first but for all
the stuff I've been through of course
you know I have to tell them like hey yo
dad like Mason a couple a lot of bad
decisions you know and this is what they
was but this is what I'm doing them to
to make sure that we okay and to show
y'all like everybody can make mistakes
and come through it
so I don't want to be which it is what
it is what it is like people know my
reputation people know I'm not with the
[ __ ] like I don't have to I don't
have to promote that you get them saying
100 that's not what I'm promoting you
get them saying I'm promoting being a
father every day you know enjoy my time
with my kids being the best dad I can be
and lovely playing football now if it
gets to a point where I have to do what
I got to do I got to do it I do you get
unsigned but of course that's not what
I'm trying to promote